Christina Aguilera goes bearer for paper  magazine the 37 year old singer looks  almost unrecognizable in minimal makeup  while gracing the current transformation  issue of the mag rocking what looks to  be nothing but a little mascara her  natural freckles and a ring that reads  mom Kristina got candid about  transformations she's undergone in her  appearance over the years and how she's  learned to appreciate her raw beauty  quote I've always been someone that  obviously loves to experiment loves  theatrics I'm a performer but I'm at the  place even musically where it's a  liberating feeling to be able to strip  it all back the freckle-faced cover  comes just days after Xtina was in full  drag glam for the season 10 premiere of  RuPaul's Drag Race say hello to the one  and only Christina Aguilera  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]